oh oh wait there's more sorry I was just
wandering around for a bit
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to corpse party I was
trying to figure this out in the
meantime but unfortunately I may have
stumbled on pong something they bleed a
little little out either way here we are
let's get into it
I'm really liking this game a lot you
can never leave you can never leave you
can never leave you can never leave
there's something a button to the side
why can I never leave the music fading
out oh the music's starting up again
good good for me what am I supposed to
do you can never leave you can never
leave but you keep changing on me what
do you mean you can never leave this is
getting very different all the time
doc dot dot exclamation point the cyber
hello oh you okay you're Evan Lee I've
what's that mean don't tell me we're
trapped what should we do shut up a Vega
dammit if we're trapped I don't know war
don't worry no way I'm letting us die in
this pigsty put a dovish we already
tried everything
we're gonna turn into two more skeletons
trapped in this room with what though
whoa what the hell just happened is it
what what whoa what is what the hell is
that
do I spit on my camera oh my god he did
sorry everybody I spit so hard out like
a drop went on my camera huh sorry
crisis is the worst start to an episode
ever okay we're good thanks everybody
all because we had to split up if
everyone else was here we might be able
to do something why did this happen
didn't I tell you to shop okay are you
so unhappy so unhappy to be trapped with
me instead of your precious [ __ ] oh she
doctor
yeah yes why why am i trapped with
someone like you oh that's mean that's
harsh and then don't tell me they're
trapped forever god that's not fun or
fair why would that happen why would
that be
that way well what am I supposed to do
okay is there a button to the side you
can never leave there had to be
something else looking closely it seems
like a few bones have been dragged away
from the rest likely a bunch of mice or
something ate some of the corpse when it
was fresh okay so so what about that
there's gotta be something I wait a
minute
I wonder how Makita is doing dr. Tommy
wait a minute what are you doing you can
never leave you can never never leave
you miss stairs off into the distance
why what does it mean what is it all
made I don't know
I'm trapped in here forever aren't I I'm
trapped forever and ever and the rest of
my tastes I shall be here forever you
can never leave but there was something
by the poster gosh dingus ching it don't
tell me that they're dead forever
because I did not do anything wrong I
may have done something wrong but I
don't think I did either way there's
more area I can go over here let me go
to the left okay did I go in here I
think it did yeah that's the infirmary
I went that way let me out thank you cut
that dramatic wait a minute there's a
flier so so chilly what the hell is that
hey stay away cuz why isn't evil spirit
saying that no the crystal cluster
suddenly shatters okay hmm
wait a minute
wait a minute why wait a minute what the
hell happened oh no no no that's where
they are I need to go in that room
they're in there I need to go in there
come on why did the crystal shard
shatter why I don't I don't get it
I'm not uh-huh-huh I'm so dumb I'm so
terribly terribly dumb I don't know what
I'm doing
so very dumb so very dumb dumb dumb okay
I guess I'm gonna save the game I have
no idea if I'm doing something great or
terrible in this game I don't know if
I'm supposed to be making these
decisions that are probably killing
everybody or if it's just what it's
supposed to happen
it's very hard to determine I have no
idea but either way I will press on by
the way I mentioned it before but I'm
really enjoying the story like I like
playing these RPG games because they
offer a lot in terms of storytelling and
they're fun to play and it's like this
one was made back in the day when the
graphics weren't great so it's really
cool to see I didn't wish the music
could change up a bit because it's
getting kind of monotonous but at the
same time I guess is catchy it's not
really what I thought would be in a
horror game then again beggars can't be
choosers it is amazing that the same
technology is being used to create games
even today Wow there it is something
else happened the hallway expanded ah ah
good good good goody goody gumdrops
chicken on the other guys and then I
obey wait what
yo shinozaki what wall it opened really
no you're gonna lie it's gonna change
its gonna make it feel like a liar we
owe it open it really did
Wow why say live in the science lab okay
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna look at the
poster again cuz I'm an idiot
em they don't think hello bones goodbye
goodbye bones what are you gonna say now
poster if you it doesn't matter if you
leave you're trapped in the school go
crazy and die well sounds like someone's
bitter why
the music changed up quite a bit this is
awesome oh wait a minute okay
Oh kid okay oh I killed the evil spirit
from the other place with the crystal I
blew it up that's awesome cool cool
awesome all right let's go
who made you King you know you could be
nicer to me I'm trying to help you but
man that music got amazingly intense so
did something change in the science lab
I'm gonna assume know so I'm gonna get
out of here I don't want to mess with
that guy any more than I have to but
things seem to be going well I want to
have any save slots I got I know I'm
gonna use them all eventually wait was
there any place where there was goopy
goo I don't remember if there was maybe
I've already gone this way and that's
where the security labs are I don't have
any keys or anything but maybe nice cous
goes back the way we came maybe use this
poster no god that is intense
I feel the beat in my butt this is
amazing
okay saw that great and I bet in a few
hours it's gonna be very monotonous but
at the same time I like it I need to
switch over to the other party because
the other party's about to make some
progress so I'm gonna go up here I'm
gonna swap over I think what was
supposed to happen is I was supposed to
actually go through and I don't know
maybe I'm supposed to get in that
trapped in that room right away no idea
but it won't budge I don't need to know
worried about the window oh that is a
lot of blood
good mints the fresh blood I can see a
crack in the wall yeah there we go
cool I'm making progress everybody wait
a minute oh well then
okay music-hall of rotten flesh is the
name of this place okay that's not a
good name could be better what is going
on how did it get quiet I don't much
appreciate that why is the wall using
slime hi
goon take care a single error may kill
someone
well that means it's time to save unless
that's an air roar okay what am I
supposed to do hello it's a female
statue it seems like something goes in
her hands oh well then - male statue it
seems like something goes in his hands
who well you know Jesu all right so I
need to go over that way to get oh no I
didn't want to talk to that okay so
that's all we got here so I'm not gonna
make any mistakes and I'm not gonna die
at least that's the plan
my plans almost always go 100% correct
except when they don't
about 50% of the time it works all the
time hello goodbye what the hell it's
speared
hello piano why are you doing hey I want
to go that way hey don't worry don't
don't sass me young man I want to play
the piano
alright then I guess I can't go that way
well then what's the point of being over
here I don't have what I need I just
pass through because I have a lever
don't tell me I got to check like every
single doorway or something I don't have
any items do I I love her forbidden key
blasted shoes you can charm okay what
else am I supposed to do
there's nothing else here alright then I
guess I gotta know where you are for me
game I don't know what you want okay
is is so quiet over there okay I'm
guessing I just need to switch over so
let's see what the other team is up to
hey tall guy won't budge I know I know I
know I already seen the letters so
basement there's an incinerator what am
I supposed to do what does it want from
me
no I'm actually lost icon everywhere why
did the music it's so intense maybe one
of these down here opened up now maybe I
can actually progress maybe I'm a
longboard yay I do I I don't know where
I picked that up I don't recall picking
that up I don't know either way I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go left
of the poster the poster itself caution
olio certified to use the incinerator
allowed to operate it well alright then
I have excellent beatab low skills they
work at building up the flame if you
know what I mean classroom 1:1 this
looks nice and decrepid letter number 3
good on earth is the secret oh yeah
there's a lot of them but I think you
think what there's a poster on the
bookshelf find the 10 letters I know you
told me that before not exactly news
buddy
so can I get into this other longboard
it's a longboard yes please I can take
as many long boards as I need because
I'm gonna need a lot I imagine because
this place is practically falling apart
I'm gonna just take everything what
longboard silly shatters I didn't want
to go that way giving me back I wanted
to go the other way
I wouldn't shatter and reappear this
place is very weird this way here we go
this looks like oh god damn it dingus
stop shattering I get it you don't want
me to go that way well I'm gonna go the
other way thank you very much yes please
come on come along now
carry on my wayward son
don't break don't break don't break
don't break don't break don't break okay
come on left a note here my beloved
sister I'm in rough shape the green
floor cuts into your leg muscles don't
walk on it please keep on living look
for what I left behind okay
there are many spirits within the school
just like humans there are good spirits
and bad spirits you can tell by their
color the calm gentle spirits have a
pale blue or green color however those
that are evil and hateful or fiery red
light to them dot dot dot it hurts
sister dearest I'm so lonely I don't
know want to die alone I'm so scared the
penmanship is too sloppy to read past
this point
mmm watch this oh god damn it's a log
don't I don't want to read it again
I didn't mean to it's like that owl from
Legend of Zelda I don't want to read it
again come on huh have you got filled
with dangerous looking broken god damn
it why would it shatter oh I know what I
need to do with it I know I know I know
I need to get to that bookshelf over
there I know exactly what I need to do
with it I got it I got it
everyone bear with me it's all trial and
error up and go this point I know
exactly what I need to do I need to make
sure because this is gonna be a very
long recording session I need make sure
that I don't scream too much so I'm
gonna be getting very close to the
microphone at times to use my sexify use
it use a longboard yeah yes yes
precisely it seems someone had dropped a
very small scrap of paper letter for you
have to press them in a certain order
you know which ones to press tell me
all right I'm first you press the
rightmost one that's a very helpful what
does that give me you are a douche you
will not give me the information that I
require Joo 9 2 - 9 2 - 9 1 hello I
whisk you away somewhere else no be that
way no I might have needed you later
2 - 9 white bones suddenly appear over
there
negative away maybe room 9 that's what
I'll that definitely wasn't there before
2 9 no way isn't this classroom 1 2
well then I need to go a floor up to 9
is written on the blackboard and a pile
of homes here from the hair appears to
be a schoolgirl well then there's
Oobleck she does step that time later on
ok so I have to buy of the shoes I can
walk through here filled with dangerous
looking broken glass 4 step to the right
thank you
seems someone had dropped a small scrap
of paper oh I missed letter 5 1 now
after that you need to hold on to the
ribbon and that's it thank you very much
very helpful well now now stop it what
are you doing sobbing I don't wanna fine
be that way
douche where are you gonna whisk me
you're gonna whisk me over there that's
what I thought
not too far so anyway I need to get some
room to 9 at least that's my
understanding
oh no I'm back in the beginning with
what classroom is that oh I want to go
back to 9 doesn't even give me an idea
what classroom it is gosh dingus damn it
I didn't want to go there this is not
too far you son of a [ __ ] I'm back
what classroom is this science lab it's
not even a classroom maybe the other
guys are able to go into a classroom let
me just go back to where I was
oh you're raising all the progress
everyone's gonna be so mad me either way
I'm gonna I'm gonna hop over to the
other guys because I don't think this is
gonna get me anywhere yes I don't think
it is anyway cuz that keeps bouncing me
back and forth so I'm assuming that the
other guys are gonna have better luck
with something else huh
one buzz yard shut I know I know I
didn't mean to interact with that so
these guys don't have anything either I
need to be able to get through that
puzzle I have the shoes that's why I
gave them the shoes there's no other
reason why I would need to there's got
to be a certain order that I triggered
them in or something like that there
needs to be a certain water class from
one one you're gonna tell me your
secrets buddy last to nine unless I need
to go back to to nine with the other
guys I don't know I'm gonna do that I'm
actually gonna do that because I think
it might be a waste of time trying to
forget this out if there's a clue into
nine that I need right now
that is more important than what I'm
doing here let's just go there and then
we I'm gonna go float like a butterfly
sting like a bee those are bad rooms I'm
assuming I'm already on the second floor
over here so if I just go over this way
I should get to where I need to go also
why is the floor covered in bile why
bile specifically biles a very specific
character on the human body class from
two four so if I go through here and I
get to the other side I should be able
to get two to nine unless it was another
area that led to tonight no it's going
in the wrong direction so someone way
over here
no it's 2-1 wait a minute why did it go
out why did the lights go out have I
been in here how about now been in here
I not been in this room okay that was
weird
that happened before why have the lights
so finicky around here this back at the
beginning wait a minute it must have
happened
I am totally unbelievably lost I'm
getting turned around unless this area
is changing or I'm just an idiot because
I played this not an hour ago I have no
idea what's going on anymore I've been
circling Rather's I don't know what I'm
doing everybody I'm assuming that I need
to go the other way
so if I go down this way oh no no no
there was just leave back to the other
bathroom will you get me to where I need
to go you didn't help me you need to
help me Gabe how do I get to where I
need to go how do i do what do you want
me to do how why I don't know this is
the first floor where am I going
why maybe I need to go damn it
take your damn it I think I need to be
on the other one because the second
floor would be up there I don't know hmm
ah I can't go in there no good we can't
get in that's two nine
what was that bloody two nine about
earlier maybe it's Mendes class I don't
know what does it all mean
the music got quiet huh scuse me what
happened don't know what [ __ ] schism
shinozaki are you okay it's bright so
bright I can barely see my own butt
no what is that oh that's your butt
anybody okay what we just whisked off
200 very nice we back home finally did
we find a way out I'm so excited can I
go home this is we our classroom it's
our classroom for real
Oh seriously look my desk you're right
is what I want to say but we finally
made it back I don't trust it I'm so
relieved
wonder how Satoshi and Co are doing I
don't know but they can't be doing good
because I don't trust this for a second
not for one ting Tong damn second wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute what
this can't be some is now right here
it's obviously ticking with me seems the
classroom is empty can't go that way as
a bulletin board over there
good work striving okay okay classroom
empty can't go that way let's just go
over to the other party and
and then why and what then happened Who
am I supposed to do this I know that
didn't get me anywhere just a
son-of-a-bitch game I don't know what
you want from me oh well let's just get
through it so those guys are now in
another dream world where there's
thinking that they're escaping when in
reality they're definitely not so what
does that mean where do I go from here
how do I even get there where is that in
relation to here I'm on the second floor
right now I don't know let me zoom back
for a little bit and then this can't be
ah are you me was that Gina's okie not
just now oh oh ah yeah what's going on
here
Kashi Numa um well it seems that part of
the building broke away you okay yeah
you know my voice gets husky when I'm
scared I may be a delicate little girl
but I have a deep voice yeah Oh Josie
goos appearing out of nowhere
well addint good there's a dead girl in
the red dress on what the heck are ya it
was a rainy after school day just like
this I I loved looking out from the
corridor and watching the rain fall but
what is she saying if you think I know
they were peaceful days when everyone
else went home and I was all alone
I was really no good with people
I had few friends most days I passed his
time alone but I didn't mind I loved
being alone I preferred it that way that
coward
that vile stain upon the fabric of
humanity he was a disgusting opportunist
as always I was alone watching the rain
fall from that corridor when I suddenly
heard my teacher from a distance I'm
worried about you he said with a kind
face he kept talking as he approached me
oh it was a such a peaceful day the
sound of rain splashing against the
building was heavenly this day would be
perfect except for that man he kept
talking to me until his lips drew close
to mine ille I was shocked the man
suddenly embraced me he then began to
rub his hands all over the MA my body in
horror I looked up at his face it was
fat ugly distorted yeah of course I
tried to shake him off and run but he
grabbed ahold of my arm and wouldn't let
go that's not good
no stop let me go teacher don't come on
you came here because you want to do it
right don't kid yourself I'll tell
everyone oh you'll never be able to
teach again is that what you want go
ahead and try it you got no friends you
think some moody introverted [ __ ] can
oust me huh
you think anyone would listen to a
pathetic wretch like you wah ha ha ha ha
ha I can't bring myself to really get
into this dialog guys oh this is rich
you poor poor thing
wah ha ha it's pretty heavy subject here
I don't want to make a joke out of it
terrible you're terrible terrible
terrible the absolute worst
why why would you say that my a bad
person did I do something wrong
even if I'm a bad person even after you
force yourself on me what gives you the
right to say that Wow
my pad I went a little too far let me
apologize Kay no biggie right let me
wipe those tears for you get away from
me stay back if you take one more step
all zombies I'll jump I'll die oh boy
you stupid [ __ ] no stay back
enough of the theatrics get down fear No
oh boy
die uh okay I died not good not good at
all I lost my footing on the edge of the
third-floor corridor and fell the
teacher and shock and horror over what
happened set out to conceal my body ah
however while trying to hide my body ran
into the principal he didn't even try to
save face he confess to everything the
principal decided and we'd be best for
the school's name to be left untouched
and agreed to help hide what happened
great because of the heavy rainfall not
a soul was around to see them awfully
convenient for those degenerates wasn't
it oh that's not good I was buried deep
inside the school basement underneath
the floorboards I was listed as missing
and eventually everyone forgot about me
terrible isn't it terrible yeah that
actually is a pretty bad story are you
saying that ghost story was true what
does this have to do with us are you
saying you're the one who dragged us
down here that is correct
are you kidding me wait there's
something I must tell you there is
another me oh I see what are you talking
about naturally I couldn't go to heaven
couldn't cross over I cursed that
teacher I cursed him in a curse em and I
cursed him over the time I had come to
hate the whole world all those people
cheerfully going about their lives faces
that never knew true suffering trapped
within this school unable to cross over
I began to view their carefree lives
with great Envy my hatred kept growing
and growing until I felt something
suddenly lift from me that was when my
spirit split I had come to resent
humanity until that resentment was all I
had my other half is in the embodiment
of all that hatred she is the one who
created these closed spaces and started
summoning people at random into here her
hatred is too strong I can do nothing to
stand against it but for some reason her
power has been weakening lately I
managed to send the two of you back home
I understand but I have one request
please save the others - doc doc doctor
I beg of you can you do that I'm sorry I
cannot why not
they're too close to her I cannot affect
your sphere of influence even though
you're both connected I'm sorry then
what the hell are we supposed to do what
do we got to do to save them that's
please tell us how to save them there is
one way tell us tell us you must head
back to the school and dig back my big
up my body then we can both rest in
peace we have to go back there I don't
recommend this if you decide to head
back I cannot return both of you to the
world a second time
but if we did nothing mo kita will die
Kiesha NEMA kishi Numa let's go we gotta
save them yes I guess we gotta huh yeah
take us back will surely rekt we'll rest
early rescue your soul I can't read I'm
in reading while are you sure if you
really want to then I'll send you both
back leave it to us
come on let's go thank you thank you so
much
you got a bread anything for friends
friends are good okay good
God doesn't really got a deep story
doing it you know that's what I've
always said about these RPG horror games
you know they don't have a lot of
graphics but they definitely emphasize
the story I am truly sorry please do
your best
maybe it wasn't such a good idea to come
back but I don't think it would have
been good to stay in the real world
anyway of all the others are over here
we all seem to be in one piece
now let's find Satoshi screw hey Keisha
Numa what's up thanks for coming with me
I know you didn't want to because you're
a coward woof Jesus like hell I am
you're just an ice queen I wish I could
say that was true but I'm actually
really scared come on let's go coward
loser ice queen whatever alright so
anyway I'm all out of time for this
episode has gotten really interesting
now the story is starting to unfold I
hope you guys are enjoying it so far
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more games that I've
done there's a ton of them and as always
I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
Jennifer
correct
not can you not
could you